PETER BRINKMANN: Hi, I'm Peter
Brinkmann, an engineer on the
speech infrastructure
team in New York.
And today I'd like to tell you
about 20% project, the
Patchfield Audio Architecture
for Android.
In a nutshell, the idea is to
allow you to implement audio
functionality, such as
synthesizers and effects, with
minimum fuss and to patch them
together in a Patchfield as
you would in a recording
studio.
The core of Patchfield is a
service that manages the
signal processing graph.
And it also acts as a central
hub for audio.
So the service manages all
your units, such as
synthesizers or effects.
And it provides all kinds
of functionality
for connecting them.
Now you can run the
service locally
in your app or remotely.
When it's running locally, then
essentially it gives you
a powerful way of organizing
audio within your app.
And it gives you also a couple
of other nice features, such
as support for formatted
processors.
When it's running remotely,
you get an added feature.
Namely, you get support for
interactive audio routing,
meaning that, say, you might
have one that just acts as a
synthesizer.
You may have another app
that acts as an effects
[INAUDIBLE].
You can connect them, and then
audio signals will flow from
one app to another, and
you get a lot of
flexibility that way.
Now in terms of APIs,
there are two APIs
for you to work with.
There's a client API in Java.
And the purpose of that Java
API is to let you query and
manipulate the signal
processing graph.
So you can get a list of the
audio modules that are
currently available.
You can connect audio modules.
You can disconnect them.
You can enable or
disable them.
And you can do a number of
other things as well.
And the second API is the
audio module API itself.
That one works with Java as well
as C. And that's what you
use for implementing new audio
functionality, such as, well,
synthesizers and effects.
All right, let's bring up
a little control app for
Patchfield.
So right now you see we have an
on/off button for enabling
or disabling audio processing.
And right off the bat, we
get two audio modules.
We get one for the microphones
of the device, so we see one
audio module that has two
outputs, one for each of the
built-in microphones.
And we see another audio
module with two inputs.
And those are the inputs for the
left speaker and for the
right speaker.
And for example, I might say
connect one of the microphones
to one of the speakers.
And if I were to turn audio
processing on right now, we
would get horrible feedback.
So let's do that.
Instead, let's launch
another app.
So this one is a very simple
app that just loads a wave
file and gets ready
to play it.
And when we go back to our
control app, we see that a new
audio module has appeared.
So now we have an audio module
for our wave file.
And let's bring up yet
another little app.
So here this app provides
a low pass filter.
And once again, if I go back to
the control app, there's as
a new module right here
that represents
our low pass filter.
And now we can connect them.
I send the audio from the wave
file into the low pass filter.
And I send the output
of the low pass
filter to the speakers.
And now if I turn on audio
processing, we
hear the wave file.
Now we can go to our
low pass filter.
And if we play with the cut off
frequency, you can tell
that the higher frequencies
go away.
So the low pass filter
acts as expected.
So that was the core
functionality of Patchfield in
a nutshell.
All right, let's take
a look at the code.
The Patchfield service
implements an interface called
iPatchfield Patchfield
service.
And this interface consists
of three types of methods.
You have methods for
manipulating the state of the
Patchfield service.
You have methods for querying
the state of the service.
And you have methods
for internal use.
So when you're manipulating the
state of the service, for
instance, you can turn on
or off audio processing.
That's what the on/off button
in the control app was for
that we saw a minute ago.
You can activate and
deactivate modules.
You can connect ports of
molecules or you can
disconnect ports.
So essentially, you can
make the changes
that you would expect.
And then you have matching
methods that tell you, for
instance, whether two
ports are connected.
You can get a list of the
audio modules that are
currently installed.
And you have a number of
other methods as well.
Now if you're implementing a
Patchfield client and you
would like to keep up to date on
changes in the state of the
Patchfield service, then
you can implement this
IPatchfieldClient interface.
Now if you register yourself
with the Patchfield service,
you will get call backs whenever
something happens.
So you might get a call back
when a module is created or
when a module is to deleted,
when ports are connected or
disconnected, and so on.
So this was essentially
bookkeeping.
The interesting part really is
the audio module API, because
that's where you implement
audio functionality.
So the foundation of it is a
class called audio molecule.
And it's an abstract task that
has four methods that you will
need to implement.
The most important
off those methods
is one called configure.
Where is it?
Here.
And the purpose of the configure
method is to connect
your audio module object to
the corresponding data
structures in the Patchfield
service.
And let's see how this
works in practice.
So let's look at the low pass
module that we saw in action
in our little demo.
So here's a module called
low pass module.
And it extends the audio module
class that we just saw.
And sure enough, it implements
the configure method that I
just mentioned.
So now this configure method
internally just takes the
handle that it received before
and the number of channels
that it wants and sends it
to a native method called
configure native components.
So let's look at the
implementation
of that native method.
That's in a file called
lowpass.c.
It's right here.
And this method allocates space
for a data structure
that will hold all the
information that characterizes
our low pass filter,
such as optic
coefficients and filter values.
And then it goes ahead and
initializes the data structure.
And now from the point of view
of the API, the most important
call is this one right here.
There's as a function
called am_configure.
And so that's one establishes
the connection between your
audio module and the
Patchfield service.
So this configure method
takes the handle that
you received early.
So you receive the handle
in the configure method.
And you just hand it over to
this function call right here.
Then it takes a process function
that you implement
and that provides the
audio processing
capability that you want.
And then you give it
the data structure
that we just created.
Let's take a look at our audio
processing function.
It's right here.
So this one initially just
retrieves the data structure
that we located earlier.
And then it extracts the filter
update coefficient from
this data structure.
And there's one crucial
point in here.
When it retrieves this update
coefficient using a GCC
built-in called
sink_fetch_and_or.
And the point here is to access
this coefficient in an
atomic way.
Because we need to worry about
threat safety here.
This coefficient may be changed
by a different threat.
When you move the slider in
the UI, then the UI thread
will change this coefficient.
But we're in the audio
thread here.
We need to make sure we're
properly synchronized, and
this GCC built-in takes
care of that.
So now once we've retrieved our
third [INAUDIBLE] update
coefficient in a threat-safe
fashion, we can do the actual
signal processing.
And that's happening
right here.
So we iterate over
our buffers.
We read our input samples.
We perform our signal
processing magic.
And we write our
output buffers.
So in particular, if you've
studied signal processing,
then you will recognize
this line right here.
This is just the update formula
although of a simple
RC low pass filter.
And that's it as far as
the code is concerned.
All right, so that's
it for now.
You can find the source
code at GitHub.
And there's a forum at Google
Groups and don't hesitate to
get in touch if you have any
questions or comments.
Happy hacking.